Dalton was a nice boy but sometimes the other boys made fun of him...
...because he was so tall and skinny.
Dalton's biggest problem was Mitch.
He was a bully who boasted about his strength.
He quarreled with the other boys.
Sometimes, if boys gave Mitch their lunch money,...
...he would have mercy and leave them alone.
One day, the boys learned about a special Middle School Olympics.
Their gym class was going to be in it.
Many kids were excited, but Dalton thought it sounded like torture.
That morning, Dalton ate plenty of carbohydrates for breakfast.
He entered the gym and looked at the dial on the clock.
It was time to begin.
The teacher asked if they were ready.
Everyone nodded except Dalton.
"I got stung by a bee. I need to see the nurse," said Dalton.
He made it up so he wouldn't have to play.
"I don't believe you. Get ready to play," responded the coach.
First, they wrestled.
Then they jumped, crawled and played other games.
But Mitch was dominant in every event.
They strained all morning to defeat him.
By lunch, they were sore.
Their entire bodies ailed them.
They thought about how to win.
They knew the last game of the day was volleyball.
Kids who used to be Dalton's rivals became his allies.
They wanted him to help them beat Mitch.
Dalton was going to be Mitch's opponent.
The game started.
Every time Mitch tried to hit the ball over the net, Dalton stopped it.
Finally, Mitch used all of his strength,...
...but the ball bounced off Dalton's hands...
...and back into Mitch's face!
Finally, Mitch was defeated.